ابراهيم طبعا لم يقتصر الامر على دهوك
واربيل هناك عده محافظات عراقيه شعرت
بالزلزال وهي محافظات جنوبيه وايضا
يتحدثون سكان في تكريت انهم شعروا في بهذه
الهزار الارضيه وتكريت طبعا هي مركز
محافظه صلاح الدين الى الجزء الشمالي من
من العاصمه بغداد
وبالاضافه الى عده محافظات اخرى قد ايقظهم
الزلزال وطبعا اربيل دهوك سليمانيه وايضا
المناطق المجاوره لها في المحافظات الموصل
وكركوك
هناك ما يتحدث انه شعروا بها بالتالي فان
اجزاء كبيره من العراق شعروا بهذا الزلزال
ولكن هنا استيقظوا وبعد بعد نزلوا الى
الشوارع خصوصا سكان العمارات السكنيه وفي
محافظات تقريب كردستان تنت اكثر عمارات
سكنيه ومجمعات سكنيه ضد طوابق طبعا طوابق
مرتفعه وهذه نسبه اكثر من بقيه محافظات
العراق التي تمتاز بالمباني الافقيه
والمدير الافقيه بالتالي فان اربيل
وسليمانيه ودهوك وربما دهوك اكثر كونها
قريبه من الاراضي التركيه ومحاذيه الى الى
جنوب تركيا صحيح ان اربيل لديها حدود مع
تركيا وطبعا لكن اربيل هو ديزل الكبير من
الحدود تقع او مناطق في محافظه دهوك على
الحديث عن مناطق العماديه دهوك نفسها
المدينه وايضا
مناطق شيخان عقره
وايضا مناطق الشماليه من اربيل مناطق
صوران
واربيل نفسها لكن اكثر هي في المناطق
المراكز المراكز المحافظات